Related visually to the class model diagram is the object diagram.
In fact they're the same with one major exception.
Instead of mentioning classes, they mention instances.
The label compartment at the top of the boxes has an underlined text line.
A text line has two parts.
One is the class name, just like in the class model diagram, but it also has
the name of a specific instance, and those two are separated by a colon.
So for example here, we have the company class, and
in particular we have the c instance of a company class.
Optic diagrams are obviously used to convey the specific use of
the classes involved in a class model diagram.
As you can see, for this particular instances here,
many of the attribute fields have attribute values filled in for
them, as they would be for a particular instance.